This is episode five of Not Built For This, The Little Levy That Could. The year I moved to California, it barely rained at all. It was 2015, and the local news was doing lots of stories about taking shorter showers and how much water it takes to grow a single almond. For most of my time in the state, California has been hovering somewhere between extreme and exceptional drought conditions. But then came the winter of 2023. The rain started on New Year's Eve. At first it was relieving, exciting even, to see the dry creek beds spring to life, and the sun-baked hills behind my house
这里是《不属于这里》的第五集，本集名为《小堤大作》。我刚搬到加州的那一年，几乎没怎么下过雨。那是2015年，当地新闻充斥着关于洗澡要快、种一颗杏仁需要多少水的报道。在我居住在那里的绝大部分时间里，加州的气候一直在极度干旱和特大干旱之间徘徊。然而，2023年的冬天来了。雨从除夕夜开始下。起初，看到干涸的小溪焕发生机，看到我家屋后被太阳晒得干裂的山丘
get a good soak. But then the water just kept coming. The storms went on for weeks on end, until we had too much of a good thing. Many rivers in Northern California flooded that winter, inundating communities that only a few months earlier had been praying for rain. The new scientific consensus is that California needs to prepare for both drought and deluge as the climate changes. Meteorologists have settled on the phrase weather whiplash to describe the bewildering snap
得到充分的滋润，人们感到宽慰，甚至有点兴奋。但随后，雨水却接连不断地下个不停。暴风雨持续了好几个星期，直到好事变成了坏事。当年冬天，北加州的许多河流泛滥，淹没了几个月前还在祈求降雨的社区。科学界最新的共识是，随着气候变化，加州需要同时应对干旱和洪涝。气象学家已经用“天气鞭笞”这个词来形容这种
from one extreme to the other. Many of the towns that felt the sting of the weather whip were low-income agricultural communities, towns like Planada and Allensworth and Pajaro, where a river broke through an old levee and displaced over 3,000 people. Following those floods, there were a lot of questions about the capacity of the state's aging water infrastructure
从一个极端戏剧性地剧烈摆动到另一个极端的过程。许多遭受天气鞭笞之苦的城镇都是低收入的农业社区，比如普拉纳达、阿伦斯沃思和帕哈罗。在那里，一条河流冲垮了一座老旧的堤防，导致3,000多人流离失所。洪水过后，人们对该州老化的水利基础设施应对
to handle supercharged storms, and about who pays the price when that infrastructure fails. But our story today is about another flood-prone farmworker town in California, one that actually managed to stay safe and dry during the big storms of 2023. It's called Hamilton City, and it's a small, unincorporated community built along the Sacramento River in California's Central Valley. For decades, the only thing protecting Hamilton City from the river was one of the worst levees in the entire state.
超强风暴的能力产生了许多疑问，也对基础设施失效时谁来买单提出了质疑。但我们今天的故事讲的是加州的另一个易受洪水侵袭的农场工人小镇，在2023年的特大暴风雨中，它竟然设法安然无恙地度过了危机。它叫汉密尔顿城，是加州中央谷地萨克拉门托河畔的一个小型非建制社区。几十年里，保护汉密尔顿城免受河水侵袭的唯一屏障，是全州最糟糕的堤防之一。
This crumbling mound of dirt was built right up against the bank, and it was full of holes. You know, it was literally like somebody put a big block of Swiss cheese along the river because it was so full of, you know, squirrels and other ground animals that just were always burrowing, and that's why it was always problematic. This is Ryan Lustor, an ecologist with the Nature Conservancy, who has worked along the Sacramento River for decades. He says that the Hamilton City levee
这个摇摇欲坠的土堆就紧贴着河岸修建，上面全是洞。你知道，它简直就像有人在河边放了一大块瑞士奶酪，因为它有太多松鼠和其他穴居动物一直在打洞，这就是为什么它总是问题不断。这是大自然保护协会的生态学家瑞安·拉斯特，他在萨克拉门托河畔工作了几十年。他说，汉密尔顿城的堤防
was slapped together on the fly by a sugar beet company in the early 20th century. You'll look at it made out of? The worst soil that they could find. This is like sandy, loamy soil. They didn't know that they needed to put clay and all that kind of stuff to make it more solid. You just had guys out there with steam shovels and horse
是20世纪初由一家甜菜公司临时拼凑起来的。你看看它是用什么做的？是他们能找到的最糟糕的土壤。这就像沙质壤土。他们根本不知道自己需要用黏土之类的东西来让它更结实。当时只有一些人拿着蒸汽铲和马拉的
drawn whatever piling up dirt just doing what they could with what they had. With only this crappy Swiss cheese levy to protect them, Hamilton City was constantly at risk of getting wiped out in a flood. And that might well have been the town's fate, were it not for the Herculean efforts of two of its residents, a fire chief and a farmer's daughter. When they set out to get a new levy for Hamilton City, they had no idea what they were getting into.
各种工具在那里堆土，有什么就用什么，尽力而为。只有这个糟糕的瑞士奶酪般的堤防保护着，汉密尔顿城随时面临着在洪水中被彻底摧毁的危险。如果不是当地两位居民——一名消防队长和一名农场主的女儿——做出了极其艰巨的努力，这可能就是该镇的命运了。当他们着手为汉密尔顿城争取新堤防时，他们根本不知道自己卷入了什么。
No idea how much of their lives would be spent trying to build a better, less whole-ridden pile of dirt. But as it turned out, they were up against powerful economic formulas that have long determined which communities are worth spending federal dollars on. Formulas that make it very hard for a small working-class town like Hamilton City to get the protective infrastructure it needs. But over the course of decades our heroes navigated a game of bureaucratic mousetrap, overcame the economic rules that were stacked
也不知道自己要花多少生命去试图建造一个更好、洞更少的新土堆。但事实证明，他们是在与长期决定哪些社区值得联邦资金投入的强大经济公式作抗争。这些公式使得像汉密尔顿城这样的小型工人阶级城镇很难获得其所需的保护性基础设施。但在几十年的时间里，我们的英雄们玩了一场官僚主义的捉迷藏游戏，克服了对他们的小镇不利的经济规则，
against their little town, and forced Hamilton City to the front of the levy line. Most of the stories in this series have been about places that are ill prepared for the extreme weather that is coming their way. But this week we have a story about a place that actually managed to get the kind of infrastructure that will help it survive climate change. Because against all odds, Hamilton City, after a lot of work, actually was built for this. I'm Emmett Fitzgerald. Wow, look at that river. Oh man, it's moving.
并将汉密尔顿城推到了筑堤排队的最前列。本系列的大多数故事都讲述了那些对即将到来的极端天气准备不足的地方。但本周我们讲的是一个成功获得了能够帮助其在气候变化中生存的基础设施的地方。因为排除万难，经过大量的工作，汉密尔顿城确实为之做好了准备。我是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。哇，看那条河。天哪，水流得好快。
I'm standing along the bank of the Sacramento with Jose Puente. He is the former Fire Chief of Hamilton City, and he's also one half of our dynamic duo. The muddy brown water is stampeding past us, and it's incredibly high. Or at least I thought it was. I've seen it higher. I've seen it higher. It's not in the biggie. He pulls out his phone and checks a website that tells him just how much water is pumping
我正和何塞·蓬特一起站在萨克拉门托河岸上。他是汉密尔顿城的前消防队长，也是我们黄金搭档中的一位。浑浊的棕色河水正从我们身边奔腾而过，水位高得惊人。或者至少我是这么认为的。我见过更高的。我见过更高的。这还不是最大的。他掏出手机，查看一个显示水流速度的网站，
through the channel. So it's almost about 90,000 cubic feet per second. Is that a lot? It's a lot of water. Yeah. Sounds like a lot. Yeah. But I have seen it where you have 150,000 cubic feet per second.
看看有多少水流经河道。所以大概是每秒90,000立方英尺。这很多吗？这是很多水。是的。听起来很多。是的。但我见过每秒150,000立方英尺的情况。
Jose scrolls through a chart that lists the strongest flows from the past. It goes back decades. Today is when Jose was a young man, and the river was running so high that it threatened to break through the old levee and flood the town. And it seems like he was here for pretty much all of those high water days, down by the river, fighting to prevent a flood. I was in that flood fight, and I was in that flood fight. Wow. And I remember that one too.
何塞翻阅着一张列出过去最大水流量的图表。数据可以追溯到几十年前。今天……何塞年轻时，河水涨得太高，险些冲破旧堤防淹没小镇。而且他似乎经历过所有这些高水位时期，一直在河边奋斗，努力防止洪水。我经历过那场抗洪，我也经历过那场抗洪。哇。我也记得那一次。
1970? 1970. — In the days of the old levee, flood fighting, as Jose calls it, was a local tradition in Hamilton City. And Jose was a legendary fighter. Ever since he was in high school, whenever there was a big storm, he'd be out here,
1970年？1970年。——在老堤防的时代，正如何塞所说，抗洪是汉密尔顿城的一项地方传统。而何塞是一位传奇的抗洪战士。从高中起，每当有大风暴，他就会来到这里，
desperately trying to plug up gopher holes and reinforce the levee. Jose points down the river to the site of one of his more memorable battles. It was kind of scary, and that particular night, we were told just to get away from here, that the river's going so high. In the middle of the night,
拼命地试图堵住地鼠洞并加固堤防。何塞指着下游他经历过的一场难忘战役的发生地。当时挺吓人的，那天晚上，由于水位太高，我们被告知赶快离开这里。在半夜里，
Jose and a couple of friends headed down to the levee to see the angry river for themselves. So we started walking from the bridge all the way out here, okay, midnight. Three idiots walking the levee. So by the time we got over here, it was like we met the sheriff at that time. We told him, he says, well, what do you think? He says, we can stop it here. All through the windy night,
何塞和几个朋友前往堤防，亲自查看那条愤怒的河。所以我们从桥上一路走到这里，好吧，午夜时分。三个在堤防上走的笨蛋。所以等我们走到这里时，我们遇到了当时的警长。我们问他，他说，嗯，你们怎么看？他说，我们可以在这里拦住它。在狂风呼啸的整夜里，
they piled sandbag after sandbag on top of the dirt to try and stop the river from breaking through. Somehow, they held the water back and Hamilton City survived the night. But even though they were victorious in that battle, Jose knew they'd never win this war. At least, not with that Swiss cheese levy. In the 70s and 80s, local leaders in Hamilton City
他们把一个又一个沙袋堆在泥土上，试图阻止河水冲破防线。不知何故，他们挡住了水，汉密尔顿城挺过了那个夜晚。尽管那场战役胜利了，但何塞知道他们永远无法赢得这场战争。至少，单靠那个瑞士奶酪般的堤防是不行的。在20世纪70和80年代，汉密尔顿城的地方领袖们
started to get fed up. They shouldn't have to evacuate the town every time there was a big storm, and rely on volunteers with sandbags to keep everybody safe. So they started asking the government for help. For a long time people kept asking our local congressmen, hey we need to address this issue of the levee. And eventually the army corps of engineers, the group that builds much of the water infrastructure in the U.S. conducted a series of reconnaissance studies on the old levy. And those reconnaissance studies always came back and said,
开始感到厌倦。他们不应该每次遇到大风暴就得疏散全镇，并且指望靠志愿者带着沙袋来确保大家的安全。于是他们开始向政府寻求帮助。很长一段时间里，人们一直在问我们的当地国会议员，嘿，我们需要解决这个堤防问题。最终，在美国建设了大部分水利基础设施的陆军工程兵团对旧堤防进行了一系列勘测研究。而这些勘测研究的结论总是：
yes, there is a problem, but you do not need the one-to-one benefit ratio. The one-to-one benefit-cost ratio. José is referring to the all-important formula that for many years has determined how the federal government spends money on stuff like levees and seawalls. Well, in order to spend federal money, the Corps of Engineers has to do an economic analysis that shows that there are going to be more benefits and damage averted from the flooding or from storms than the cost of the project. This is Rob Young.
是的，确实有问题，但你们达不到一比一的效益比。一比一的效益成本比。何塞指的是那个至关重要的公式，多年来，它决定了联邦政府如何在堤防和海堤等项目上花钱。嗯，为了花联邦资金，工程兵团必须进行经济分析，证明防洪或风暴减少的损失和带来的效益将大于项目的成本。这是罗布·扬。
He's a professor of geology at Western Carolina University and an expert on the way the federal government thinks about flood infrastructure. Rob says that basically before the Army Corps can go build an expensive levy with taxpayer money, they have to show that the value of the property it would protect is at least as much as the cost of the project. Which, you know, on the surface sort of makes sense, right? I mean, you don't want to spend $5 billion of federal money for $10 of benefits.
他是西卡罗来纳大学的地质学教授，也是联邦政府关于防洪基础设施思维方式的专家。罗布说，基本上，在陆军工程兵团用纳税人的钱去建造一个昂贵的堤防之前，他们必须证明它所保护的财产价值至少要等于项目的成本。这在表面上似乎说得通，对吧？我的意思是，你不会想花50亿美元的联邦资金来换取10美元的效益。
But there's a pretty massive problem with making decisions about who gets a levy based on property value. The richer you are, the more likely you are to get federal flood protection. It biases our flood protection projects to expensive infrastructure and away from those who probably need the help the most. Rob is particularly critical of the Corps for funding projects that protect the beachfront second homes of wealthy people. Wealthy people who could probably afford to pay for their own flood protection.
但根据财产价值来决定谁能获得堤防，存在一个非常大的问题。你越富有，就越有可能获得联邦防洪保护。这使我们的防洪项目倾向于昂贵的基础设施，而远离那些最需要帮助的人。罗布特别批评工程兵团资助那些保护富人海滨第二住宅的项目。那些富人本来可能支付得起他们自己的防洪费用。
And the reason for that is not that the Corps is evil or they're just mean, but it's this ingrained system of the economic analysis. Ultimately, that ingrained economic analysis means that if you're a small working class town along, say, the Sacramento River in California, for example, and you really need a new levy, you're pretty much screwed. The way the system works right now, if you don't have high value property, then you're much less likely to get federal protection. Just as simple as that.
原因并不是工程兵团邪恶或刻薄，而是这种根深蒂固的经济分析系统。归根结底，这种根深蒂固的经济分析意味着，如果你是一个位于加州萨克拉门托河畔的小型工人阶级城镇，而且你确实需要一座新堤防，那你基本上就完蛋了。就目前的系统运作方式而言，如果你没有高价值的财产，那么你获得联邦保护的可能性就会小得多。就是这么简单。
For decades in Hamilton City, it really was just as simple as that. The town kept asking the government for help, but every time the Army Corps ran the numbers, help was not cost effective. Here's José Puente again. I think that the federal government kind of figured that it's a lot cheaper if we pay for the damage versus doing an investment on the construction of the levy. But even though the math was stacked against them, Jose was determined. By the 90s, he'd become the head
在汉密尔顿城，几十年来确实就是这么简单。该镇一直向政府寻求帮助，但每次陆军工程兵团计算数字时，得到的结论都是寻求帮助并不具成本效益。再次听到何塞·蓬特的说法。我认为联邦政府某种程度上觉得，如果我们支付损失赔偿，比对堤防建设进行投资要便宜得多。尽管数学公式对他们不利，但何塞并没有放弃。到了90年代，他已经成为了
of the Hamilton City Fire Department, and he'd been fighting floods for literally half his life. He was tired of it. And so, Jose decided he was going to make it his mission to get Hamilton City the new levy it deserved. He didn't know anything about federal infrastructure policy, but how hard could it really be? mission to get Hamilton City the new levy it deserved. He didn't know anything about federal infrastructure policy, but how hard could it really be? We had no idea.
汉密尔顿城消防局的局长，而且他literally（字面意义上）花了一半的人生在抗洪。他对此感到厌倦。因此，何塞决定将为汉密尔顿城争取应得的新堤防作为自己的使命。他对联邦基础设施政策一无所知，但这到底能有多难呢？将为汉密尔顿城争取应得的新堤防作为自己的使命。他对联邦基础设施政策一无所知，但这到底能有多难呢？我们当时一无所知。
We didn't understand what we were getting into. I mean, for us, when we started, it was a shot to the moon, okay? It was a dream. Jose started rallying people in town together in pursuit of that moonshot. They formed an official organization and they wanted an official sounding name, something that people would have to take seriously. They went with Hamilton City Citizens in Action, which they shortened to the CIA. We put CIA.
我们不明白自己卷入了什么。我的意思是，对我们来说，刚开始的时候，这就像登月一样，好吧？这是一个梦想。何塞开始召集镇上的人们为了实现这个“登月梦想”而共同努力。他们成立了一个官方组织，并希望起一个听起来很官方的名字，一个人们必须严肃对待的名字。他们选择了“汉密尔顿城行动市民”（Hamilton City Citizens in Action），简称“CIA”（中情局缩写）。我们用了CIA。
When we, our first event that we did, people really thought it was CIA. In order to recruit people to the CIA, Jose would go around town giving a little spiel about the need for a new levy to anyone who would listen. I would see him at all of our nonprofit meetings, the Lions Club, the Women's Club, that type of thing. Him coming everywhere, church. I would see him all the time coming, giving his speech. I need help. We need help. We have an issue. And you know, the more people that get involved, the better off we are. This is Leanne Grigsby-Puente.
当我们举办第一次活动时，人们真的以为那是中情局。为了招募人员加入CIA，何塞会在镇上到处跑，向任何愿意听的人滔滔不绝地讲我们需要新堤防的必要性。我会在我们所有的非营利组织会议上看到他，比如狮子俱乐部、妇女俱乐部之类的。他到处跑，甚至去教堂。我经常看到他到处发表演讲。我需要帮助。我们需要帮助。我们遇到了一个问题。你知道，参与的人越多，对我们就越好。这是莉安·格里格斯比-蓬特。
And I was like, what? What is he talking about? Leanne didn't know that much about the levy or the Army Corps of Engineers and its benefit-cost ratio. She also didn't really know that much about Jose, but she understood his sense of urgency. I was raised in agriculture. We know what it's like to have to protect the land and the power of water. And that's what a lot of people don't understand. And she thought she might have something to offer. I mean, I can take notes.
当时我的反应是，什么？他在说什么？莉安对堤防、陆军工程兵团及其效益成本比并不太了解。她对何塞也不是很了解，但她理解他的紧迫感。我在农业环境中长大。我们知道保护土地和水资源的力量意味着什么。这就是很多人不理解的地方。她觉得她或许能帮上忙。我的意思是，我可以记笔记。
I can make an agenda. You know, I can answer a phone. I can make phone calls, you know, those types of things. I can do that. So I asked him, I said, I want to help. What can I do? And next thing I knew, I was coming to big meetings And I was like, oh, what did I get into? Pretty soon, Leanne was a fixture at these meetings.
我可以拟定议程。你知道，我可以接电话。我可以打电话，你知道，诸如此类的事情。我能做到这一点。所以我问他，我说，我想帮忙。我能做些什么？接下来的事我顺理成章地参加了大型会议，当时我的反应是，天哪，我这是卷入了什么？不久之后，莉安成了这些会议上的常客。
And she and Jose became partners in crime. Leanne was the talker, the mouthpiece for the organization. While Jose was quietly getting stuff done behind the scenes. They started spending so much time together working on the Levee project that they became really close. A few years after founding the CIA, they got married. Your whole relationship is based on the levy. And a rodent levy, so you can even imagine.
她和何塞成了志同道合的搭档。莉安是那个健谈的人，是该组织的代言人。而何塞则在幕后默默地把事情做好。他们花了很多时间在一起为堤防项目工作，以至于他们的关系变得非常亲密。成立CIA几年后，他们结婚了。你们的整段关系都是建立在堤防的基础上的。还是一个与啮齿动物有关的堤防，你简直无法想象。
But Hamilton City's new power couple was facing an uphill battle. Because even if they could somehow get the Army Corps of Engineers to agree that it was worth it to build them a new levee, it turns out Hamilton City would actually need to pay for part of it. With big infrastructure projects like this, the local people have to make a significant contribution to the cost, usually 25 to 35% or so, which for a big city can be fine, but for a tiny unincorporated community like Hamilton City was pretty much impossible.
但汉密尔顿城这个新的权力核心组合正面临着一场硬仗。因为即使他们能以某种方式让陆军工程兵团同意为他们建造新堤防是值得的，事实证明，汉密尔顿城实际上需要为此承担一部分费用。对于这样的大型基础设施项目，当地居民必须为成本做出重大贡献，通常是25%到35%左右。对于大城市来说这可能没问题，但对于像汉密尔顿城这样微小的非建制社区来说，这几乎是不可能的。
Well, there was no way that the locals could meet the 25%. It wasn't exactly clear how much that would be, but it was certainly in the millions and potentially in the tens of millions of dollars. They weren't going to raise that money all at once, but they needed to start somewhere. And Leanne and Jose came up with an idea. They would throw a levy festival in downtown Hamilton City and ask all the best cooks in town to volunteer.
嗯，当地人根本不可能承担25%的费用。虽然具体数额不是很清楚，但肯定在数百万美元，甚至可能达到数千万美元。他们不可能一下子筹集到这笔资金，但他们需要从某个地方开始。莉安和何塞想出了一个主意。他们将在汉密尔顿城市中心举办一个堤防节，并邀请镇上所有最好的厨师来当志愿者。
And to our surprise, everybody said yes. So if your family was good at making tamales, then that family did tamales. If your family was good at making carnitas, then that's who made the carnitas, carne asada, tacos, corn on the cob. Citizens in Action started hosting one or two lee festivals a year.
令我们惊讶的是，每个人都答应了。所以，如果你的家族擅长做玉米粉蒸肉（tamales），那么这个家族就做玉米粉蒸肉。如果你的家族擅长做墨西哥烤肉（carnitas），那么做烤肉的就是他们，还有烤肉卷（carne asada）、玉米卷（tacos）、玉米棒。行动市民组织开始每年举办一两次堤防节。
They were fundraisers, but also acts of political theater to show the powers that be just how badly this little community wanted a new Levee. They would invite local politicians and nonprofits and people from the Army Corps, and they knew that they wouldn't have any problem getting the people of Hamilton City to show up. We're lucky Jose is probably related to half the town.
这些活动既是筹款活动，也是一种政治表演艺术，旨在向当权者展示这个小社区对新堤防的渴望有多么强烈。他们会邀请当地政客、非营利组织和陆军工程兵团的人，而且他们知道，要让汉密尔顿城的人民出席，他们不会有任何问题。我们很幸运，何塞可能跟半个镇子都有亲戚关系。
Not so lucky for our children and our grandchildren. Is that true Jose? You related to half the town? About a quarter of it. These Levee festivals were always well attended, although Leanne admits that a lot of people were probably just coming for the tamales. It was our biggest moneymaker and by the end of the levies, when we stopped doing the festivals, we were up to 60 dozen an event.
对我们的子孙后代来说可不怎么幸运。是这样吗，何塞？你跟半个镇子都有亲戚？大约四分之一吧。这些堤防节总是座无虚席，尽管莉安承认很多人可能只是为了玉米粉蒸肉而来的。这是我们最大的赚钱渠道，到堤防节结束时，当我们停止举办这些活动时，我们每场活动能卖出多达60打。
We sold out in two hours. If you wanted tamales, you had to get there first, okay? Because within two hours, they were sold. Politicians that came in said, we're just in here for tamales. And it was like, hey, you're late. They're gone. The Levee festivals were really successful fundraisers. They made it possible for the town to hire a lawyer who knew
我们在两个小时内就卖光了。如果你想要玉米粉蒸肉，你得先到那儿，好吧？因为在两个小时内，它们就卖光了。来的政客们说，我们是专门来吃玉米粉蒸肉的。而我们的反应是，嘿，你们来晚了。卖完了。堤防节是非常成功的筹款活动。它们让该镇有可能聘请一位精通
his way around federal infrastructure policy. But Leanne and Jose were nowhere near the millions of dollars they needed for the local contribution to the cost. They needed help. And in the year 2000, help arrived in the unlikely form of an ecologist. So how does a community of 2,000 people that's severely economically disadvantaged come up with millions of dollars? They're not going to do that selling tamales. This is Ryan Lustor from The Nature Conservancy. And he would end up being a key part of the solution
联邦基础设施政策的律师。但莉安和何塞距离支付本地分摊费用所需的数百万美元还差得远。他们需要帮助。2000年，救星以一位生态学家的意想不到的形式出现了。那么，一个严重处于经济劣势的2,000人社区怎么能筹集到数百万美元呢？他们靠卖玉米粉蒸肉是做不到这一点的。这是来自大自然保护协会的瑞安·拉斯特。他最终成为了解决汉密尔顿城面临的
to the two seemingly insurmountable obstacles facing Hamilton City. How to raise millions of dollars, and how to get around the all-important benefit-cost ratio. Ryan was working along the river doing habitat restoration when the federal government made a key tweak in how they calculated the ratio. Basically, they said if you could design a levee that also restored habitat, they would take that into account when they were calculating whether the project was worth spending money
两个看似不可逾越的障碍的关键部分。如何筹集数百万美元，以及如何绕过至关重要的效益成本比。瑞安当时正在河边做生境恢复工作，这时联邦政府对他们计算比例的方式进行了关键性的调整。基本上，他们说如果你能设计一个也能恢复生境的堤防，他们在计算该项目是否值得花钱时会将这一点考虑在内。
on. They said you can now include ecosystem benefits in your calculations. And when the folks in Hamilton City heard about this, they thought that could be the solution to our benefit cost problem. So that's why the community came to us and said, hey, will you guys partner with us and help us, you know, with the restoration side of this? And we said, absolutely. And when you say the community, how much was that Jose and Leanne?
他们说你现在可以在计算中纳入生态系统效益。当汉密尔顿城的人们听到这个消息时，他们认为这可能是解决我们效益成本问题的方法。这就是为什么社区找到我们，说，嘿，你们愿意与我们合作，在恢复方面帮助我们吗？我们说，当然愿意。当你提到社区时，何塞和莉安占了多大比重？
It was pretty much them. Yeah. And so, Ryan and Jose and Leanne and a bunch of local farmers started working together. And I really can't stress enough what a surprising collaboration this was. In this part of California, farmers and conservationists are often on the opposite sides of disputes about how to use land and water. Leanne grew up in an old farming family, where environmentalist was a dirty word. I was an adult in my 30s when I came and worked on this project.
基本上就是他们俩。是的。于是，瑞安、何塞、莉安以及一群当地农民开始合作。我真的怎么强调这是一次多么令人惊讶的合作都不为过。在加州的这个地区，农民和环保主义者在如何使用土地和水的问题上经常处于争端对立面。莉安在一个老牌农场家庭长大，在那里环保主义者是个贬义词。我当时三十多岁，是个成年人了，当我来做这个项目的时候。
And all I could think of is if my grandfather knew what I was doing right now, he'd be so upset. And for his part, Ryan certainly never thought he was ever going to be a part of an effort to build a levee. In fact, Ryan had spent much of his career trying to undo all the damage that levees had caused. Because you look at a levee, it's like, oh, that's bad for the ecosystem, right? In order to better understand why levees have traditionally been so bad for the rivers of the Central Valley,
我脑子里想的唯独一件事就是，如果我爷爷知道我现在在做什么，他一定会非常生气的。就瑞安而言，他绝对从未想过自己会参与建造堤防的努力。事实上，瑞安职业生涯的大部分时间都在试图消除堤防造成的破坏。因为你看一个堤防，就会觉得，哦，这对生态系统不好，对吧？为了更好地了解为什么传统上堤防对中央谷地的河流一直这么糟糕，
I took a trip to the newest state park in California. It's called Dos Rios, and it's the site of one of the largest floodplain restoration projects in the state. Welcome to the next California State Park. Yeah. Let's check it out. Yep. My guide for the day is Austin Stevenot, a field manager with the organization River Partners and a member of the Northern Sierra Miwok Tribe.
我去了加州最新的州立公园。它叫多斯里奥斯，是该州最大的洪泛区恢复项目之一。欢迎来到下一个加州州立公园。好的。我们去看看吧。是的。我今天的向导是奥斯丁·史蒂沃特，他是“河流伙伴”组织的一名实地经理，也是北塞拉米沃克族的成员。
We're walking through a shady grove of oak trees along the San Joaquin River. These trees are probably 100 years old and for whatever reason weren't cleared. But this is right in front of you is kind of a glimpse of what it might have actually looked like. And that's why I brought you here. Austin says that hundreds of years ago, the Central Valley looked completely different than it does today.
我们正走在萨克拉门托河畔一片阴凉的橡树林中。这些树可能有一百年历史了，不知何故没有被砍伐。但这就是你眼前的景象，可以说是它原本样子的惊鸿一瞥。这就是我带你来的原因。奥斯丁说，几百年前，中央谷地的面貌与今天完全不同。
It was covered with a vast mosaic of riparian forests and wetlands that were tended by different indigenous groups. There were tuli elk roaming through the marshlands and grizzly bears feeding on the massive salmon runs. They talk about the salmon run was so immense that at night you could hardly sleep sometimes because there's so many salmon coming up the river, you could just hear them.
这里长满了由不同原住民群体照料的河岸森林和湿地大拼图。有罗斯福马鹿在沼泽地里漫步，灰熊则以庞大的鲑鱼群为食。他们说鲑鱼洄游的规模太大了，以至于有时晚上你根本无法入睡，因为有那么多的鲑鱼逆流而上，你光是听都能听到它们的声音。
This region doesn't get a lot of rain, but the wetlands were irrigated naturally by the rivers that meandered across the valley floor. During winter storms and the spring snowmelt, the Sacramento and the San Joaquin would fan out across the landscape. Occasionally, during really big floods, the entire central valley was transformed into a vast inland sea. It turned the valley into a giant lake, essentially. But in the 19th and 20th century, farmers took over the valley and settled in little towns like Hamilton City. And for them, these erratic seasonal floods
这个地区雨水不多，但湿地得到了蜿蜒穿过谷底的河流的自然灌溉。在冬季风暴和春季融雪期间，萨克拉门托河和圣华金河会在整个景观中扇形散开。偶尔，在真正的大洪水期间，整个中央谷地会变成一片巨大的内陆海。它基本上把山谷变成了一个巨大的湖泊。但在19和20世纪，农民接管了山谷，并在汉密尔顿城这样的小镇定居下来。对他们来说，这些不规律的季节性洪水
were deeply inconvenient. The idea became that we needed to control the rivers, right? Because you didn't want the river jumping up and flooding out your field that you had just planted in the springtime. So they started building levees. They dammed the rivers and built levees right up against the banks to prevent the floods,
带来了极大的不便。当时的理念是我们必须控制河流，对吧？因为你不想让河水暴涨并淹没你在春天刚刚种下的田地。于是他们开始建造堤防。他们筑坝拦河，紧贴着河岸修建堤防以防止洪水，
effectively cutting off the wetlands from their water source. Today, the valley is mostly dry, dusty farmland. The marshes and the forests are almost entirely gone. We've lost 95% of this ecosystem up and down the state in the last hundred years, so it's – a lot of people don't know about it or understand it. Levees enabled much of the 20th century development in the Central Valley. But that came at an enormous ecological cost. And it also hasn't guaranteed safety
实际上切断了湿地与其水源的联系。今天，该山谷大部分是干燥、尘土飞扬的农田。沼泽和森林几乎完全消失了。在过去的一百年里，我们在全州范围内失去了95%的这种生态系统，所以很多人并不知道它或不理解它。堤防促进了中央谷地20世纪的大部分开发。但这付出了巨大的生态代价。它也没有保证安全，
because when levees are built right up against the banks of the river, the water has nowhere to go. It can't spread out like it once did. And if there's a big storm, like the ones we should expect with climate change, the river just gushes through the channel with increasing ferocity.
因为当堤防紧贴着河岸修建时，水无处可去。它无法像以前那样扩散开来。如果有大风暴，就像我们因气候变化而应该预期的那样，河水就会以越来越猛烈的势头从河道中喷涌而出。
And if it gets high enough and angry enough, it can overtop or bust through a levee and flood the towns and fields that were supposed to be protected. But our unlikely team of farmers and conservationists had an idea for a different kind of levy at Hamilton City, a levy that would be good for both the town and for the river.
如果水位变得足够高、足够汹涌，它就会漫过或冲破堤防，淹没本应受到保护的城镇和田野。但我们这支由农民和环保主义者组成的意想不到的团队，为汉密尔顿城设想了一种不同类型的堤防，一种对小镇和河流都有利的堤防。
And we all came together. We all had a common purpose, okay? For the community and the farmers, the interest was flood protection. For the environmental community, they had the interest on restoring land back to its natural habitat. The idea was that instead of building a new levee
我们走到了一起。我们都有一个共同的目标，好吧？对社区和农民来说，利益是防洪。对环保界来说，他们的利益在于将土地恢复到其自然生境。这个想法是，与其在河岸边建造新堤防，
right along the bank of the river, they would set it back a mile or so inland, closer to the edge of town. And then, and here's the part that Ryan was particularly into, they would tear down the old one. We need to remove the levee that's along the river so that the river now has room to spread out. Room for the river. The technique of making room for the river comes from the Dutch, and the logic is pretty simple.
不如把它向内陆退后大约一英里，更靠近小镇边缘。然后——这就是瑞安特别感兴趣的部分——他们将拆除旧堤防。我们需要拆除河边的堤防，以便河流现在有空间扩散开来。给河流腾出空间。为河流腾出空间的技术来自荷兰，其逻辑非常简单。
Instead of trying to tightly control the river in this narrow channel, you want to give it more room to spread out across the floodplain. This is not only good for the ecology of the river, but it's safer for people, because it slows the water down and makes it less dangerous. And when the river floods, it's not really a problem, because the water just flows onto a floodplain that was designed to get wet. So instead of fighting nature, let's use nature to our own advantage.
与其试图在这个狭窄的河道中严格控制河流，不如给它更多的空间在洪泛区上扩散。这不仅对河流的生态有利，而且对人们更安全，因为它减缓了水流速度，降低了危险性。当河流泛滥时，这其实不是问题，因为水只是流入了一个旨在被淹没的洪泛区。因此，与其与自然对抗，不如利用自然为我们自己谋利。
I mean, you're using nature and in this sense, the floodplain, the floodplain is what we're using. It's a storage facility, plain and simple. They drew up a plan for this new setback levee. And as part of the proposal, the Nature Conservancy agreed to buy the 1,400 acres of farmland between the river and the new levy and donate it to the project. That land value would count as Hamilton City's local contribution to the cost of the project.
我的意思是，你在利用自然，在这个意义上，洪泛区，洪泛区就是我们所利用的。它是一个蓄水设施，就这么简单。他们为这个新的退堤计划绘制了蓝图。作为提案的一部分，大自然保护协会同意购买河与新堤防之间的1,400英亩农田，并将其捐赠给该项目。这块土地的价值将被算作汉密尔顿城对项目成本的本地配套投入。
Then, Ryan and his colleagues would do all of the landscape design work to transform that floodplain into the kind of rich ecosystem that might have been there hundreds of years ago. In 2004, the team got the Army Corps of Engineers to do a feasibility study of their new Setback Levy Plan, and they said, hey, this time it's different. This time you have to consider all of these habitat benefits when you calculate the benefit-cost ratio. The Army Corps ran the numbers. And when you added that dollar value of the habitat
然后，瑞安和他的同事们将完成所有的景观设计工作，将该洪泛区改造成几百年前可能存在的丰富生态系统。2004年，该团队让陆军工程兵团对他们的新退堤计划进行了可行性研究，他们说，嘿，这次不同了。这次你们在计算效益成本比时必须考虑所有这些生境效益。陆军工程兵团计算了数字。当你把生境的美元价值
plus the dollar value of the flood risk reduction, that's where we get the total benefits. And this time, the benefits were greater than the costs. Hamilton City passed the test, and the Corps gave the project their seal of approval. The new levy was deemed worth it, all because of the habitat restoration. And you might be thinking, great, problem solved.
再加上减少洪水风险的美元价值，这就是我们得到的总收益。而这一次，收益大于成本。汉密尔顿市通过了测试，陆军工程兵团对该项目给予了批准。由于栖息地的恢复，人们认为新的堤防是值得的。你可能会想，太好了，问题解决了。
Story over, Hamilton City gets the protection it deserves. But not so fast. Because it turns out that even if the Army Corps of Engineers approves a plan, that doesn't mean it has the money to actually go through with it. And to get the federal government to pay for its portion of a levy, you have to go convince them. And I don't mean send a really compelling email.
故事结束，汉密尔顿城获得了应有的保护。但别急。因为事实证明，即使陆军工程兵团批准了一项计划，也并不意味着它有钱真正去执行。要让联邦政府为其部分的堤防买单，你必须去说服他们。我的意思不是发一封极具说服力的电子邮件。
I mean, you have to go convince Congress in person. What they will tell you is, you got to get the funding from Congress. You have to go to Washington seeking those funds. Coming up after the break, Jose and Leanne go to Washington. When we left off off it was 2004. Jose and Leanne and Ryan had just managed to get approval for a feasibility study for their setback levy. But Congress
我的意思是，你必须亲自去国会说服他们。他们会告诉你的是，你得从国会获得资金。你必须去华盛顿寻求这些资金。中场休息后即将播出，何塞和莉安前往华盛顿。当我们中断时，时间是2004年。何塞、莉安和瑞安刚刚设法获得了他们退堤计划可行性研究的批准。但国会
controls the purse strings for federal infrastructure projects. And getting them to actually pay for things is a whole other process that itself can take years. And it's a process that is also biased against small working-class communities like Hamilton City. Before working on this story, a thing that I didn't really appreciate about big infrastructure projects like this is that you're competing against every other project across the country for funding. And it's not like there's some super fair and reasonable process to decide who needs that money the most.
掌握着联邦基础设施项目的钱袋子。要让他们真正掏钱是另一个完全不同的过程，这个过程本身可能需要数年时间。这也是一个对像汉密尔顿城这样的小型工人阶级社区带有偏见的系统。在着手这个故事之前，我没有真正意识到关于这样的大型基础设施项目的一点是，你正在与全国各地的其他每个项目竞争资金。而且这并不像有什么超级公平合理的过程来决定谁最需要这钱。
Here's Rob Young again, our flood infrastructure expert. So much of the resilient spending that's available today relies on that community having the capacity to go after that money. He says that if you want that money, you have to put together a proposal and go lobby against every other city in town over who gets included in the federal budget. And you're up against other communities that have lobbyists and attorneys and full-time planners and GIS staff that can put together a hell of a nice looking shiny proposal.
再次请出罗布·扬，我们的防洪基础设施专家。今天可用的许多有韧性的支出很大程度上依赖于该社区去追逐这些资金的能力。他说，如果你想要这笔资金，你必须整理一份提案，并与镇上的其他所有城市争夺谁能被纳入联邦预算。而你的竞争对手是其他社区，他们拥有说客、律师、全职规划师和GIS（地理信息系统）员工，能够拼凑出一份看起来棒极了的光鲜提案。
So that tends to be where most of the funding goes. Small communities or communities that are not incorporated, they tend to fall by the wayside because they just don't have the ability to even step up to the table to get some of that funding. And they tend to be the ones who need to help the most. Hamilton City didn't have a planning department or a GIS specialist or a team full of lobbyists, but they did have the Nature Conservancy and the CIA. And so Jose and Leanne and Ryan and
因此，大部分资金往往流向了那里。小社区或未建制社区往往被边缘化，因为他们根本没有能力甚至无法走到谈判桌前去争取其中一部分资金。而他们往往是最需要帮助的人。汉密尔顿城没有规划部门、GIS专家或说客团队，但他们有大自然保护协会和CIA。因此，何塞、莉安、瑞安和
their lawyers went all the way to Washington, D.C. to try and convince a bunch of suits on Capitol Hill that little old Hamilton City deserved a levy more than all of the other cities and towns in the country. When the team first arrived in Washington, they got a little boost when they learned that legend of the Hamilton City Levee festivals preceded them. When we went back to Washington, DC, we were at the Pentagon. The first thing that came I was getting a tamales. We did not bring your tamales to the Pentagon. Sorry. We didn't think that they would allow them to come in here. They go like, hey, trust me, they got in.
他们的律师一路前往华盛顿特区，试图说服国会山上一群穿西装的人：小小的汉密尔顿城比全国其他所有城市和城镇更配得上一个堤防。当团队第一次抵达华盛顿时，他们得知汉密尔顿城堤防节的传奇故事在他们之前就已经传开了，这让他们备受鼓舞。当我们回到华盛顿特区时，我们在五角大楼。我到的第一件事就是有人要玉米粉蒸肉。我们没有把你们的玉米粉蒸肉带到五角大楼。抱歉。我们以为他们不会允许它们进来。他们说，嘿，相信我，它们进来了。
You know, that was the Tamale diplomacy. On these visits, our Tamale diplomats would meet with the Army Corps and members of Congress and their staffs. Jose and Leanne would try to do the trip in just two or three days to save money. So sometimes we were taking red eyes landing and going directly to work. I've done that. It's terrible. Yeah, it's horrible. And on the last day, you work all the way up until six o'clock and then you get to the airport as fast as you can and try to get out of there so you don't have to
你知道，那是玉米粉蒸肉外交。在这些访问中，我们的玉米粉蒸肉外交官会见了陆军工程兵团、国会议员及其幕僚。何塞和莉安会试图在短短两三天内完成行程以节省资金。所以有时我们坐红眼航班落地然后直接去工作。我做过那事。太糟糕了。是的，太可怕了。而在最后一天，你一直工作到六点钟，然后尽可能快地赶往机场，试图离开那里，这样你就不用
pay for another hotel room. It was not cheap. It was not easy. And it was intimidating, even for Ryan Luster. He had more experience lobbying than Leanne and Jose, but even he felt a little out of his depth. You know, sitting in the Pentagon, talking about habitat restoration, it's like, am I in the right place?
再付一晚的酒店房间钱了。这并不便宜。这并不容易。这令人畏惧，即使对瑞安·拉斯特来说也是如此。他比莉安和何塞有更多的游说经验，但即使是他也觉得自己有点力不从心。你知道，坐在五角大楼里，谈论生境恢复，感觉就像，我是在正确的地方吗？
This seems kind of odd. Who were you pitching in those moments in the Pentagon? The Army. You're sitting there with people in uniform telling them about elderberry beetles and these Bells of Vario birds and why we should plant more oak trees. And they're looking at you like,
这似乎有点奇怪。你在五角大楼的那些时刻向谁推销？陆军。你坐在那里，对面是穿制服的人，向他们讲述接骨木甲虫和贝尔斯维里奥鸟，以及为什么我们应该种植更多的橡树。他们看着你的眼神就像是，
what are you talking about? Jose, for his part, never thought that he would be in Washington, DC, meeting with senators and generals. But he also figured out pretty quickly that it was all a game and that he could play it as well as anyone. When you get there, it's like you're actually in charge. You know, you know what you're going to talk about. They don't. So you have to sell yourself within the first five minutes. Jose and Leanne went to DC more times than they could count in the 2000s. Year after year, they made the trip.
你在说什么？就何塞而言，他从未想过自己会去华盛顿特区会见参议员和将军。但他也很就弄清楚了，这全是一场游戏，他可以像任何人一样玩好它。当你到达那里时，感觉就像你才是真正负责的人。你知道，你知道你要谈论什么。他们不知道。所以你必须在头五分钟内把自己推销出去。在2000年代，何塞和莉安去华盛顿的次数多得数不清。年复一年，他们踏上了这趟旅程。
And year after year, they got turned down. I'm not sure why they kept at it. Maybe at a certain point, it just felt like they'd invested too much to give up now. Or maybe they just really understood that the existence of their town was at stake. But whatever it was, their persistence caught the attention of some high-powered people in Washington. Leanne's in particular. She was relentless.
年复一年，他们遭到拒绝。我不确定为什么他们能坚持下来。也许在某个特定时刻，他们只是觉得他们已经投入了太多，现在放弃不了了。或者也许他们真的很清楚，他们小镇的生存正处于危急关头。但无论是什么，他们的坚持引起了华盛顿一些大人物的注意。特别是莉安的坚持。她毫不妥协。
And what was really different with Leanne was that she took the time to understand the process, which is not common. This is Congressman John Garamendi, who represented the Sacramento Valley at the time. He says that it felt like Leanne knew every inch of what seemed to him like a very complicated project. Talking to her was like talking to a hydrologist, a farmer, and a floodplain ecologist all rolled into one bundle of energy. And on top of that, she knew her way around a labyrinth of government agencies. She knew what the Army Corps of Engineers needed. Fish and wildlife, the federal agencies. Congressman Garamendi got to know Leanne and Jose very well over the years.
莉安真正与众不同的是，她花时间去了解这个过程，这并不常见。这是当时代表萨克拉门托河谷的国会议员约翰·加拉门迪。他说，感觉莉安对在他看来非常复杂的项目的每一个细节都了如指掌。和她说话就像是和一个水文学家、一个农民和一个洪泛区生态学家交谈，所有这些都融为一个充满精力的整体。最重要的是，她熟知政府机构的迷宫。她知道陆军工程兵团需要什么。鱼类和野生动物管理局，联邦机构。多年来，加拉门迪议员对莉安和何塞有了非常深入的了解。
He says they became fixtures around the Capitol. They were back here at least every three to four months. Did you ever get tired of them? Oh, God, no. No, no, they were just the energy that they brought to the discussion was such that you never get tired of that kind of energy. You would simply feed on that energy and you'd want to work whatever was necessary to complete their dream.
他说这些人成了国会山周围的常客。他们至少每三到四个月就会回来一次。你有没有对他们感到厌烦过？哦，天哪，没有。不，不，他们带给讨论的那种能量，让你永远不会对那种能量感到厌烦。你只会从这种能量中汲取力量，并且会想要完成他们梦想所需的任何工作。
But the dream just wasn't coming to fruition, and the years just kept piling up. The 2000s bled into the 2010s, and back in Hamilton City, people were starting to get impatient. It had been over a decade since the Levee festivals first got going. Years of supporting this project with basically nothing to show for it. So we'd have to go back to the community every three years and say, okay, we know the last time we were here and we told you it was just going to be one more year.
但这个梦想就是迟迟无法实现，年复一年不断堆积。20世纪90年代转眼进入了2010年代，汉密尔顿城的居民们开始失去耐心了。距离堤坝节最初举办已经过去十多年了。多年来一直支持这个项目，却基本上没有什么成果。所以我们每隔三年就得回到社区说，好吧，我们知道上次来的时候告诉过大家，只需要再等一年。
I mean, one more year, one more year, one more year, one more year, one more year. I mean, it just kept going on and on and people were starting to be like, uh. And if the community was getting tired of this saga, imagine how Leanne and Jose were feeling. They were devoting hours and hours of their time, week after week, year after year. The Levee Project had become one of the central tent holes of their life. Originally we were told, oh, you know, this project is going to take about four or five years.
我是说，再等一年，再等一年，再等一年，再等一年，再等一年。我的意思是，这事情没完没了，人们开始表现出“呃”的反应。如果说社区对这段漫长的波折感到厌烦，想象一下莉安（Leanne）和何塞（Jose）当时的感受。他们日复一日、周复一周、年复一年地投入了大量的时间。堤坝项目已经成为他们生活中最核心的支柱之一。起初有人告诉我们，哦，你知道，这个项目大约需要四五年时间。
And so we said, oh, four or five years, that's not bad. So then the next thing is, you know, those five years, six years, eight years, ten years, 15 years, and you're going like, what the hell's going on? Did you ever almost give up? Were there moments in this process where you were like, I don't know if we can keep doing this? There were frustrating moments when we were just like, done, I'm cooked. And then something, it happened almost every single time, something big and exciting would
于是我们说，哦，四五年，那还不错。然后接下来你知道的，五年、六年、八年、十年、十五年过去了，你会想：到底怎么回事？你有没有差点放弃过？在这个过程中，有没有那么一刻让你觉得：我不知道我们还能不能坚持下去？确实有过沮丧的时刻，当时我们就觉得：完蛋了，我彻底凉了。然后总会有一些事情发生——几乎每次都是这样——总会有重大且令人兴奋的事情
happen. Just that little bit of movement that got us back into where we were, okay, we can do this. We can do this. I think part of the reason they were able to keep the faith was that the project just felt like it made too much sense not to happen. Farmers liked it. Environmentalists liked it.
发生。正是那一点点的进展，让我们重回正轨，心想：好吧，我们能做到。我们能做到。我想他们能够保持信念的部分原因在于，这个项目本身让人觉得实在太合情合理了，不可能不成功。农民喜欢它。环保主义者喜欢它。
The Army Corps liked it. And so Leanne and Jose and Ryan just kept making the case that this was a win-win no-brainer of a project. And eventually, in 2014, close to 20 years since they threw that first levy festival, the government finally agreed. The Hamilton City Setback Levy was included in that year's federal budget. We were chosen. There were hundreds of projects that we were competing with, and this was one of them. That was a really big deal. For Leanne and Jose, they couldn't admit that it was really happening
陆军工程兵团也喜欢它。因此，莉安、何塞和瑞安不断阐述这样一个观点：这是一个双赢、无需多想的项目。最终，在2014年，距离他们举办第一届堤坝节近20年后，政府终于同意了。汉密尔顿城后退堤坝项目被纳入了当年的联邦预算。我们被选中了。当时有数百个项目在竞争，而我们是其中之一。这真的是一件大事。对于莉安和何塞来说，他们简直不敢相信这一切真的在发生
until they saw the clouds of dust from all the construction equipment arriving in town. I literally stood out in my front yard and watched the first dump truck leave the project. I seen him go in, and I seen him come out. I think when we saw the equipment, that's when it was like, okay, we're done. Did you go celebrate? People think, oh, did you have a big party? No, we did not. We literally went out on the levy,
直到他们看到涌入镇上的各种施工设备扬起阵阵尘土。我真的站在前院，看着第一辆自卸卡车驶离项目工地。我看着它进去，又看着它出来。我想，当我们看到那些设备时，那种感觉就是：好吧，我们成功了。你们去庆祝了吗？人们可能会想，哦，你们办了大派对吗？不，我们没有。我们实际上是走到堤坝上，
had a cocktail and said, thank you, Lord Jesus. Thank you, Lord, because it just took so long. You may have noticed that there hasn't been a whole lot of talk about climate change in the story up until this point. That's mostly because when Jose and Leanne were getting started with all this, climate change was a distant threat in people's imaginations. But it's not a distant threat anymore. And as people in California struggle to cope with drought and deluge, the Hamilton City Setback Levy is starting to look like money very well spent. Because it turns out one of the best tools to prepare for extreme rainstorms and big flooding events
喝了一杯鸡尾酒，然后说：“感谢主耶稣。感谢主。”因为这实在是花了太长时间。你可能已经注意到，在这个故事的前半部分，并没有太多关于气候变化的讨论。这主要是因为当何塞和莉安刚开始着手做这件事时，气候变化在人们的想象中还只是一个遥远的威胁。但它不再是一个遥远的威胁了。正当加州人民艰难应对干旱和暴雨交加的困境时，汉密尔顿城后退堤坝项目看起来越来越像是一笔极其划算的投资。因为事实证明，应对特大暴雨和重大洪水事件的最佳工具之一，
is a setback levee just like the one in Hamilton City. This was not designed to be a climate-based adaptation project, but it turns out it is. This is exactly what you need to deal with future climate scenarios. And we, I don't know if I want to say we were lucky that the project can fit that new need, but it does. Ryan thinks that Hamilton City should be a model for the Army Corps of Engineers, or really anyone trying to keep people safe
就是像汉密尔顿城那样的后退堤坝。这个项目在设计之初并不是一个基于气候变化的适应性项目，但事实证明它确实是。这恰恰是应对未来气候情景所必需的。而且我们——我不知道该不该说我们很幸运，这个项目正好契合了这种新需求，但它确实契合了。瑞安认为，对于陆军工程兵团或者任何试图在超级暴雨频发的时代保障人们安全的人来说，汉密尔顿城都应该成为一个模范。
in an era of supercharged rainstorms. Not just in California, but the entire country. And what's frustrating about that is that you would think because it checks all the boxes, well, why isn't it being replicated? Some aspects of the project are being replicated. The Army Corps of Engineers recently built a brand new setback levy downriver from Hamilton City in West Sacramento. And all throughout the country, from Northern California
不仅在加州，而且在全美都是如此。令人沮丧的是，你会想，既然它符合所有条件，那为什么没有被复制推广呢？项目的一些方面正在被复制。陆军工程兵团最近在西萨克拉门托市汉密尔顿城下游修建了一座崭新的后退堤坝。在全国各地，从北加州
to my hometown in Vermont, people are coming around to the idea that making room for the river is one of the best ways to prepare for extreme rainstorms. But whether Hamilton City can provide a workable blueprint for other small, working-class towns that desperately need protective infrastructure? I'm not so sure.
到我的家乡佛蒙特州，人们逐渐开始接受这样一种观点：为河流腾出空间是应对特大暴雨的最佳方法之一。但是，汉密尔顿城能否为其他迫切需要防护基础设施的小型工薪阶层城镇提供一个可行的蓝图？我不太确定。
I mean, it's wonderful that you can point to an example where with a tremendous amount of perseverance and maybe a little bit of luck and outside assistance, we have a community that proved it could be done. Again, here's Rob Young. But, you know, I loved playing baseball and no matter how hard I work, I'm not going to be Shohei Otani. And so we, you know, we can't expect all of these communities to be able to pull it off in the same way.
我的意思是，你能指出这样一个例子，在付出巨大的毅力、或许还有一点点运气以及外界协助后，一个社区证明了这是可以做到的，这当然很棒。再次听听罗伯·扬（Rob Young）的说法。但是，你知道，我喜欢打棒球，无论我多么努力地训练，我都成不了大谷翔平。所以，你知道，我们不能指望所有这些社区都能以同样的方式办到这一点。
For one thing, not every little town has a Jose and Leanne, the Shohei Otanis of Levy Building. What happened in Hamilton City is a cool story, but it doesn't change Rob Young's assessment of the overall problem. Any way you cut it, the deck is stacked against these small poor communities. And Rob's not naive.
首先，并不是每个小镇都有自己的何塞和莉安——筑堤界的大谷翔平。汉密尔顿城发生的事情是一个很酷的故事，但它并没有改变罗伯·扬对整体问题的评估。无论你从哪个角度来看，这些贫穷的小社区都处于劣势。罗伯并不是天真。
He knows as well as anyone that we just won't be able to protect every community in the years ahead. That's just not possible. I mean, we have thousands of miles of coast. We have probably tens of thousands of miles of floodplain along rivers in the U.S. along rivers in the U.S. You know, the idea that we can guarantee protection to everybody, it's just not feasible. But if we can't build everyone a levy, we have to think long and hard about who is going to get the levies that we do build. Rob says that we need to have a national triage conversation
他比任何人都清楚，在未来的岁月里，我们根本无法保护每一个社区。这是绝对不可能的。我的意思是，我们拥有数千英里的海岸线。在美国的河流沿岸，可能还有数万英里的洪泛平原。你知道，那种我们可以保证每个人都受到保护的想法，根本是不切实际的。但是，如果我们不能为每个人都修建堤坝，我们就必须认真思考，究竟是谁能获得我们真正修建的堤坝。罗伯说，我们需要进行一场全国性的分诊式对话，
about how we want to use our resources, about which communities should get priority and why. And again, it all comes down to what we value as a nation. These are our funds. These are public tax dollars. Certainly one would hope that the only calculus isn't going to be property value when we're talking about providing flood protection. In recent years, the Army Corps actually has started to rethink the benefit cost ratio.
讨论我们如何使用资源，哪些社区应该获得优先权以及为什么。归根结底，这一切都取决于我们作为一个国家所珍视的东西。这些是我们的资金。这是公共税收。人们当然希望，在讨论提供防洪保护时，唯一的计算标准不会仅仅是房产价值。近年来，陆军工程兵团实际上已经开始重新思考效益成本比。
There is rulemaking in the works right now that could transform how the Corps makes decisions about who gets protection. You know, there are a wide variety of reasons why you might choose to invest those federal dollars beyond simply protecting high value real estate. But even if we do change the values that drive how these decisions are made, I think the Hamilton City story points to another massive problem as we try to adapt our infrastructure to climate change, which is speed. As disasters pile up all around the country, people need protection and they need it fast. And this whole process just takes so much time.
目前正在进行的规则制定工作可能会改变工程兵团在决定谁能获得保护时的决策方式。你知道，除了单纯保护高价值房地产之外，你选择投入这些联邦资金的原因可能还有很多。但是，即使我们改变了驱动这些决策的价值观，我认为汉密尔顿城的故事也指出了我们在试图使基础设施适应气候变化时的另一个巨大问题，那就是速度。随着灾难在全国各地不断堆积，人们需要保护，而且他们需要迅速得到保护。而整个过程却需要耗费如此多的时间。
Here's Leanne Grigsby-Puente again. We've had people from out of the area ask us, how do you do this? And we always tell them, are you willing to put 25 years of your life in this to make sure it gets done? Because that's what we did. And that's what we tell them. I kind of couldn't believe it when I heard Leanne say that. Like, if I was one of those people trying to build a levy and I got that advice,
再次听听莉安·格里格斯比-蓬特（Leanne Grigsby-Puente）的话。我们有当地以外的人问我们：“你们是怎么做到的？”我们总是告诉他们：“你愿意把25年的生命投入到这上面来确保它完成吗？”因为这就是我们所做的事情。这就是我们对他们说的。当我听到莉安这么说时，我简直有些不敢相信。就好像如果我是那些试图修建堤坝的人之一，而我得到了这样的建议，
I would give up right there on the spot. And as proud as Jose is of what they've accomplished, even he's not sure it was worth two decades of his life. I mean, if somebody was to ask me, hey, would you commit to this again? I don't know. On the one hand, I think this is a hopeful story of a small town overcoming the odds
我当场就会放弃。尽管何塞为他们所取得的成就感到自豪，但连他也不确定这是否值得他耗费二十年的光阴。我的意思是，如果有人问我：“嘿，你愿意再承诺做一次吗？”我不知道。一方面，我认为这是一个充满希望的故事，讲述了一个小镇克服重重困难，
to get the kind of forward-thinking infrastructure it deserves. But on the other hand, it feels like they never should have had to work this hard. And the thing is, they're still not done. Ryan Luster says they need a couple more years to finish the habitat restoration. My goal is December of 2026. Probably is going to bleed into 2027. 27 years. Who's going to spend 27 years on a project?
获得了它应得的具有前瞻性的基础设施。但另一方面，感觉他们本不应该付出这么大的努力。问题是，他们还没有完工。瑞安·拉斯特（Ryan Luster）说，他们还需要几年时间来完成栖息地恢复工作。我的目标是2026年12月。可能会延续到2027年。27年。谁会花27年时间去做一个项目？
I mean, I guess it's kind of a rhetorical question because I almost did. I guess just like when we're thinking about all the work that needs to be done to like adapt our infrastructure and adapt the way we're living to the challenges that are coming our way, it's you know, it's a hopeful story. And it's also a it's a sobering story. Exactly. It's a very sobering. Yeah, it's very sobering. But it's it shows that it's not impossible. that it's not impossible. This past winter, 2024, California got hit with more big storms. I wanted to see the new levee in action.
我的意思是，我想这算是个反问句，因为我几乎就这么做了。我想，就像当我们思考为了让基础设施适应环境、让我们的生活方式适应即将到来的挑战而需要做的大量工作时，你知道，这是一个充满希望的故事。同时这也是一个清醒的故事。没错，这是一个非常清醒的故事。是的，非常清醒。但它表明这并非不可能。这并非不可能。去年冬天，即2024年，加州遭遇了更多大风暴。我想看看新堤坝投入使用的实际效果。
And so on a rainy weekend, I drove up to Hamilton City to meet with Jose. I said, we're on the Mazda today. OK, cool. Oh, yeah, the old truck. The old truck. It looks good. Yeah. It's an old beige pickup, one of those perfect tiny trucks they don't make anymore. Yeah, no, my baby's showing his age.
于是在一个下雨的周末，我开车去汉密尔顿城见何塞。我说，我们今天开马自达吗？好吧，酷。哦，对，老卡车。老卡车。它看起来真不错。是的。这是一辆旧米色皮卡，那种他们不再生产的完美小卡车。是的，不，我的宝贝显老了。
How many miles? Oh, I got 300,000. 300,000? That's pretty good. Yeah. We take the old truck up onto the new levee. It honestly isn't much to look at, just a big wall of dirt. It's hard to believe how much time and money it took to get this built, but it makes all the difference in the world.
跑了多少英里了？哦，我开了30万英里。30万英里？那相当不错了。是的。我们开着老卡车上了新堤坝。老实说，它看起来没什么特别的，只是一堵巨大的泥墙。很难相信建造它花了这么时间和金钱，但它带来了天壤之别。
On the other side is the floodplain, a giant space that's designed to fill right up with water, so that the town stays dry. Jose says there was a moment the night before when it was really raining quite hard. But instead of heading down to the levee with a bunch of sandbags, he went to bed. After many years, it's comfort to know that you can sleep better. Towards the end of our tour, we get to a spot where the river has flowed over the bank and onto the floodplain. It's not a lot of water, but it's enough that you can appreciate the way this landscape might have looked before, when this whole valley was a wetland.
另一边是洪泛平原，这是一个巨大的空间，设计成注满水，以便小镇保持干燥。何塞说，前天晚上雨下得非常大，当时有过那么一个时刻。但他没有带着一堆沙袋赶往堤坝，而是上床睡觉了。多年之后，这种能够睡个好觉的安稳感是一种慰藉。在参观快结束时，我们来到了一处河水漫过河岸流入洪泛平原的地方。水不是很多，但足以让你领略到这片土地以前的面貌，当时整个山谷都是湿地。
Oh wow, look at all the birds. Yeah. Ducks. Yeah. They go where the water goes. See, this gives you a different perspective, doesn't it? Yeah. Totally.
哦，哇，看那些鸟。是的。鸭子。是的。水往哪里流，它们就去哪里。看，这给了你一个不同的视角，不是吗？是的。完全是这样。
It's a beautiful scene. It almost makes you want to tear down all the levees and bring back the inland sea. Of course, that is a terrible idea. There are millions of people living in this valley, and the food grown here supports millions more. You can't let the rivers run wild. But you also can't just keep patching holes and crumbling old levees built right up against the riverbank and hope for the best. The Setback Levee at Hamilton City may not be a perfect model for every vulnerable river town, but I think it offers a hopeful vision of compromise.
这是一个美丽的场景。它甚至让你想拆掉所有的堤坝，把内陆海重新带回来。当然，那是个糟糕的主意。这个山谷里生活着数百万人，这里种植的粮食养活了更多的人。你不能让河流肆意泛滥。但你也不能总是修修补补那些紧邻河岸摇摇欲坠的老旧堤坝，然后祈祷一切顺利。汉密尔顿城的后退堤坝可能不是每个脆弱河滨小镇的完美模范，但我认为它提供了一个充满希望的妥协愿景。
Proof that we can design for people and for nature at the same time. That we can choose to loosen our grip, relinquish some control, and give the river a little more room to breathe. When we got back to the lot where my car was parked, the winds had died down. The storm was just about over. Where are you headed now? Going home. Nice.
事实证明，我们可以同时为人类和自然进行设计。我们可以选择放松我们的掌控，放弃一部分控制权，给河流更多的呼吸空间。当我们回到我停车的停车场时，风已经停了。风暴差不多要结束了。你现在要去哪里？回家。太好了。
Going home. Maybe take a nap now? Going home. Nice. Maybe take a nap. I don't know. You've you've earned it. All right. Next time on Not Built For This. So far this series has been all about the way climate change is impacting how and where we live. It's been about things like housing and infrastructure and insurance. But coming up on our final episode, we have a story about the impact of climate change
回家。现在也许可以睡个午觉？回家。太好了。也许睡个午觉。我不知道。你——你这是应得的。好的。下一期的《非此设计》。到目前为止，这个系列一直在探讨气候变化如何影响我们生活的方式和地点。它关乎住房、基础设施和保险之类的事情。但在即将播出的最后一集中，我们将讲述气候变化对我们的身体产生的影响。
on our bodies. We're going to Phoenix, Arizona to see how extreme heat is revealing the biological limits of adaptation. Our thermometers top out at 109, and personally I've had multiple patients that have come in that have maxed out our thermometers. All we can do is try to find a shady spot to sit. Most times we're stuck out in the sun. It really sucks.
我们将前往亚利桑那州凤凰城，看看极端高温是如何显现出人类适应能力的生理极限的。我们的温度计最高显示到109华氏度（约43摄氏度），就我个人而言，我有好几个接诊的病人，他们的体温已经让我们的温度计爆表了。我们能做的就是找个阴凉的地方坐着。大多数时候我们都被困在太阳底下。这真的很糟糕。
It's hot, nasty, muggy, dirty, filthy, just all around bad news. This episode of Not Built For This was reported and produced by me, Emmett Fitzgerald, along with producers Jason DeLeon and Sophie Kodner, and managing editor Delaney Hall. Further invaluable editing from Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and our standard bearer, Roman Mars. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez.
天气炎热、讨厌、闷热、肮脏、污秽，简直是全方位的坏消息。本集的《非此设计》由我埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）以及制作人杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）和苏菲·科德纳（Sophie Kodner）、总编德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）共同报道和制作。克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）以及我们的旗手罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）提供了非常宝贵的编辑意见。混音和声音设计由马丁·加利扎（Martin Gonzalez）完成。
Theme and original music by George Langford from Actual Magic, with additional music by Swan Rayal. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Series art by Aaron Nestor. Special thanks this week to everyone we spoke with in Hamilton City, as well as Alicia Kircher from the Army Corps of Engineers, and Bill Paris, who was a lawyer for the community.
主题曲和原创音乐由来自Actual Magic的乔治·兰格福德（George Langford）创作，斯旺·拉亚尔（Swan Rayal）提供额外音乐。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦基安（Sona Avakian）负责。系列美术由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。本周特别感谢我们在汉密尔顿城交谈过的每个人，以及来自陆军工程兵团的艾莉西亚·基尔切尔（Alicia Kircher）和社区律师比尔·帕里斯（Bill Paris）。
I also wanted to shout out the organization River Partners, which is doing a lot of the remaining restoration work at the Hamilton City site. Not Built for This is a six-part series from 99% Invisible. Our final episode will be out on Friday, wherever you get your podcasts. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstedt is our digital director. The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Barube, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Gabriella Gladney, Jacob Maldonado Medina, and Nina Potuck.
我还要向“河流伙伴”（River Partners）组织致敬，他们在汉密尔顿城遗址进行了大部分剩余的修复工作。《非此设计》是来自99%无形（99% Invisible）的六集系列节目。我们的最后一集将于周五发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它。卡西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kolstedt）是我们的数字总监。99PI团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Ley）、拉沙·马多恩（Lasha Madon）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriela Gladney）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）和妮娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）。
The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. You can find 99% invisible on all of the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that and every episode of 99PI and Not Built For This at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99%无形的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的全新Discord服务器上找到99%无形。在99PI.org上有一个链接，指向该网站以及99PI和《非此设计》的每一集。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。